house-to-house - okay the house - most
people said the house - let's do that
then no I want to show you guys what we
just saw okay
that is less than what I was having
nightmares about last night
legend has it that there is a house in a
small town and has been closed and left
empty for decades the house belonged to
a wealthy family but then one day old
family members father mother daughter
and the maid committed suicide what from
that time the neighbors have closed the
house for good as they believed that the
house where all family committed suicide
is cursed
sounds like The Grudge some said that
they may have heard a woman screaming
voice from that house you misspelt women
by the way yet no one dared to enter the
house are you why would you open that
door open it this is how I pay for them
this is how I play point-and-click
adventure games just like
during the face is gonna come up check
the blood stain
man that's a freak yeah I'm not supposed
to be a charming family photo this feels
like it's very jump-scare
damnit
I prefer I don't like jumps gagging Ziva
I feel they kind of like it's like cheap
thrills hey I never saw anything come on
I was like when you watch these like
stupid like movies and yeah I actually
feel like that's what we're waiting for
yeah and and is this time - do I have to
wait today's event statement because
these events like I didn't do anything
to actually make those things happen
why would you still be in this house
after that happen I would just turn tail
neck nope nope oh we on look at the boss
I know like both rooms is scary oh man
oh man finally the deal of this game is
you repeatedly click on things until
something scary happen why am I in this
house
the peeping tom in the shower should
think about using a pin sometime so
that's the dab oh I guess each of the
minor committed suicide in a separate
room age so like mother the father the
dad sorry the mother the father the
daughter and the may that's
ignore that omission breaking things
actually this little Facebook like pot
is actually pretty I don't want to see
the little girl that's so scary
this is my K I have to say I can put in
a highlight show a lot of people think
I'm putting this [ __ ] on I'm not very
physically uncomfortable
I get very affected by horror things it
made me very upset for no reasonable
reason I enjoy it and I see the value in
it but I get very infected and neither
do I are the kind of person to pretend
with skit or not
everything you see is legit if we're not
scared by a game they'll be pretty fun
okay's and poisoned dude I why she's
hanging out bulls now it's even worse
when she's not there
I'm coming
it's a birthday yeah it's her birth year
so it would have been oh yeah we saw it
and the best difficut there's nothing
scary in here
they won't be right why why have to die
mom I want to live no matter what she's
gonna jump out boys
oh sorry wait [ __ ] [ __ ]
Oh
oh wow okay they go it's not a true
story okay thank you good old photos
messages and story have been made oh
don't worry I store it for anyone
worried hi Soren oh we found a key to
the special room [ __ ] the special room
Audrina was born in 1947 severely
disabled they knew that she must have
been suffering would never have a good
future so the couple poisoned her and
put her a dead body into the safe
putting the body of this like singer she
looks like box go and she crawled out of
it that was the house too you can search
that if you if you wish to experience
that for yourself
don't do it um apologies for those who
came and expected us to play at my house
difficulties we got two of those woods
all right pretty good not quiet night
lady night
yeah that was pretty good yeah we'll try
again as I've said before we'll play
whatever you guys want to see yeah so
whether it's something to play before
like nine-minute house we can get
running or anything else leave your
suggestions on our HOH live hashtag on
twitter if you're so inclined or you can
do so in the comment sections of YouTube
or GameSpot
yeah thanks everyone thanks bye